would you rather throw up any time  someone says mcdonald's or wear a fedora  for the rest of your life and if anybody  asks you about it you have to say i like  the way it looks yuck give me the puke  oh my god it is tough though i know  you're going to be walking around and  there's going to be advertisements it's  not when you see it though right yeah so  you could just walk around going like  anytime you see that golden arch you  just plug your ears  you don't even have to hear it ever  wearing a fedora is tough you can't  escape that even if you're not walking  around going i like the way it looks  you might as well start talking that way  if you're wearing a fedora though that's  why everyone who wears a fedora is a  jag-off because  they're all  in it they're digging their heels in to  whatever it is that's going on that gave  them the fedora and then they have to  say dumb [ __ ] like i like this